we're going to have hotter drier summers
in our cities
um we're going to have to deal with more
frequent and more intense heat waves
it's going to have an impact on our
health and well-being but not just us
what about the plants and animals that
call our cities home
so what can we do about that
we could green our cities we could plant
trees the shade provided by trees
provides protection from those impacts
of the heat
but what do we need to make those plants
thrive and survive
we need water
our green cities need water
but mosquitoes also like
water and so how can we balance the
impacts that come from both of those if
we perhaps are inadvertently creating
increasing pest and public health risks
for ourselves in the ways in which we
try to respond to a changing climate
how can we green our cities and not
create a problem with mosquitoes now
mosquitoes are the deadliest animals on
the planet
about half a million people die every
year because of mosquito bite
diseases such as malaria and dengue
infect hundreds of millions of people
every year across the planet
that burden of disease weighs quite
heavily on both communities and local
authorities as they struggle to try to
deal with those impacts
here in australia we're very fortunate
to be free of some of the more serious
mosquito-borne diseases but there are
still pathogens spread by our local
mosquitoes that can make us sick
so something like ross river virus
if we get infected with this virus we
may not die but we could get seriously
ill
fever rash joint pain fatigue we could
be battling illness for many months
but notwithstanding the burden of
disease what about the nuisance that
mosquitoes can have just to our
day-to-day lives how many of you been
bothered by mosquitoes when you're
outside enjoying the
the barbecue or visiting the local
wetlands during summer what about that
mosquito that buzzes around your bedroom
at night
how can we manage these risks
um and move forward and try to live in a
greener city and not create
opportunities for mosquitoes
so i spend my summers sloshing about in
wetlands wrangling mosquitoes
despite the sunburn and the mosquito
bites and the mud i actually do quite
like my job
and i've also got a confession to make
to you all
i actually quite like mosquitoes
i'm quite fascinated by them
i think they're actually quite beautiful
if you get a chance to look at them
underneath the microscope
so before i started my research and
first looked underneath the look through
a microscope at a mosquito i don't think
i'd really given them much of a thought
i knew that they were involved in
outbreaks of disease overseas and i was
quite familiar with that smell of a
smoldering mosquito coil it still
reminds me of summer holidays
but the work i do now together with that
of scientists around the country is
trying to work out how we can stop
people getting sick because of mosquito
bites it requires us to understand
the role mosquitoes have in our local
environment and how we can change our
cities so that we're greening our cities
we're mitigating those impacts of
climate change but at the same time not
creating opportunities for mosquitoes
did you know there are over 60 different
types of mosquitoes that are found in
western sydney
so it's not just that one mosquito that
you slap on your arm and squashed
they're an incredibly diverse and
interesting range of animals
there's 60 different types across
western sydney
these mosquitoes might be big they might
be small
they might be black with distinctively
striped legs
they might be a pale brown color or they
might be a really vibrant orange color
but one of the things i love about all
these mosquitoes is that they're very
unique they've adapted to very different
types of environments it's one of the
reasons i like them because they're
incredibly adaptive but it's also the
thing that worries me about them
because they could be adapting to these
sources of water we're creating around
around our cities
so mosquitoes are found in an incredibly
wide range of environments from coastal
rock pools to snowmelt streams in our
alpine regions from polluted drains to
pristine wetlands and almost every
puddle of water in between there are
mosquitoes found in all of these
environments and understanding how the
mosquitoes interact with these
environments and the climate is really
important to understand how they might
play a role in outbreaks of disease
but all of these mosquitoes essentially
need two things
they need blood
and they need water
so i'll get to the blood in a little
while but let me talk you to you about
why water is really important for
mosquitoes
the humble mossy is a really frail and
fragile creature it looks like it'll
fall apart in a strong breeze it's hard
to imagine these are the dangers most
dangerous animals on the planet
but these animals kind of rely on water
they've got an amazing life cycle that
starts in the water they need water so
eggs are laid in and around sources of
water and then when it rains or the
tides come into the wetlands these eggs
hatch and out of these eggs hatch these
worm-like larvae that swim around in the
water maybe you've seen them in puddles
or your pot plant sources or maybe as i
did as a child if you're a bit slow to
clean your backyard swimming pool when
the warmer weather arrives all of a
sudden you can see these mosquitoes
swimming around at the top of the water
but during summer it might only take a
week or so for them to emerge from those
from that water and start flying around
they only live for a few weeks but
during that time they can bite a lot of
people
and they can lay more than a thousand
eggs
but to get those eggs they need blood
mosquitoes need blood that's why they
bite
it's only the female mosquito that bites
and she needs that protein hit in her
blood to develop her eggs they can live
quite happily on plant juices and sugars
most of the time but they really need
that blood to develop eggs and the
animals they can get that blood from can
be incredibly varied from cows and
kangaroos to birds to frogs
but also us
and i know for some of you that's in
this room you're probably thinking boy
mosquitoes sure like to bite me a bit
more than they like to bite my friends
and sometimes we can be bitter unlucky
like that
but it's also important to remember that
mosquitoes when they bite can not only
create an itchy red lump on our skin but
they can also make a sick
they can transmit pathogens that make us
sick but mosquitoes aren't flying around
transferring droplets of infected blood
from person to person these are not
dirty syringes
they're much more complicated organisms
and so the mosquitoes themselves have to
become infected with the pathogen before
they can pass that on to us and when it
comes to pathogen transmission not all
mosquitoes are created equal
it's why it's really important to
understand mosquitoes because even
though we have dozens of mosquitoes here
in sydney that could transmit something
like ross river virus
there are no mosquitoes currently in
sydney that can transmit the pathogens
that cause more serious diseases things
like dengue chikagonia or zika
let's hope it stays that way so does a
green city look like for a mosquito
so first of all there are trees
that provide shade protection from wind
and sun it provides these kind of
protected humid little areas where
mosquitoes can take refuge the longer
mosquitoes live the more people they
bite the more eggs they lay
but it's not so much the plants but the
water they need which is really critical
for mosquitoes
so in a green city we have water tanks
we build wetlands
we've got green walls and frog ponds
we've got bio retention basins we've got
rain gardens all of these structures
that might be designed to store and
recycle water in and around our cities
and suburbs could be used by mosquitoes
remember mosquitoes love this water
that's available to them
so how can we design a city so that
mosquitoes aren't quick to adapt to
these types of environments wherever
there's water mosquitoes will lay eggs
and we have to be mindful about that as
we try to respond and green our cities
create these structures that will help
us it'll make a city greater i want to
live in a green city
i would love to live in a green city
it's probably great for my physical and
mental health and well-being i just
don't want to share that with too many
mosquitoes
and mosquitoes are so adaptive that i'm
sure that they're going to create
opportunities in these structures that
we're building and so i'm really worried
that we're going to see more and more
mosquitoes into the future
so how do you create a wetland that's
not home to mosquitoes
well one of the really interesting
pieces of research we've found in recent
years is that problematic mosquito
populations often seem to be associated
with wetlands of poor health
wetlands that have more stagnant water
wetlands that don't have enough
predators to eat the mosquitoes
so it's a tantalizing idea that if you
can create a wetland that's healthier it
has more water flow it has a greater
level of biodiversity you can actually
keep mosquito populations down
if you provide habitats for the animals
that eat mosquitoes the birds the bats
the fish the frogs the spiders the any
number of aquatic insects that love
munching on mosquitoes
rather than being a problem
mosquitoes they're not going to
disappear we're not going to get rid of
mosquitoes completely but if they're in
a more balanced place in the ecosystem
maybe we'll have fewer pest impacts and
more importantly maybe we'll see less
mosquito-borne disease
but what about stormwater drains these
are already a common site in our local
wetlands and there's a mosquito that
calls these habitats home which you all
already know
you may not notice it when it flies past
you
but you know it's sound you've probably
learned to hate the sound of this
mosquito more so than it's bite
this is a mosquito called the brown
house mosquito it loves breeding in
polluted ponds and pipes and waterways
it's going to be quick to exploit the
ways in which we store waste water
around our cities
the thing is about this mosquito is that
love's coming indoors at night it's the
mosquito that's going to be buzzing
around your face at night keeping you
awake disrupting your sleep
now the reason you can hear that
mosquito is not because it makes a sound
that's different to any other mosquito
it's just that a mosquito prefers to
bite birds and so i was flying around
your face and your body responding to
your heat and the smell of your skin
working out is this a large featherless
bird i'm not sure whether i want to bite
it or not
and that's bad luck for those of you who
smell a bit like a bird
but it's a reminder that sometimes it's
not just the bite of mosquitoes it's the
problem it's the disturbance that we can
be caused by large numbers of mosquitoes
and so we don't want these mosquitoes
coming inside our homes where we're kind
of creating opportunities for these
mosquitoes in their cities
so what about our backyards
we all want to keep our backyards
healthy we want to have create a great
opportunity for our plants and our pets
and the local wildlife one effective way
to do that is installing a rainwater
tank the problem is rainwater tanks can
be a great source from from very serious
mosquitoes
you all in this room have probably been
bitten by the australian backyard
mosquito its scientific name is edes
nodoscriptus
it is the most widespread mosquito in
australia almost everybody has
opportunities for this mosquito in the
backyard whether it's a bird bath a pot
plant saucer even the smallest volumes
of water trapped in a water hole and
container will be a place this mosquito
can last eggs
it's a nuisance biting pest
but it's not a serious threat to our
health
but there's a problem here
because these same habitats where this
mosquito is found
could also be the home of a mosquito
that's fat that's associated with the
transmission of much more serious
pathogens
pathogens that can cause outbreaks of
disease such as dengue chikagounia and
zika
these mosquitoes are the asian tiger
mosquito or the yellow fever mosquito
these two mosquitoes are not found in
sydney at the moment but worldwide they
contribute to major outbreaks of
mosquito-borne disease
they don't breed in wetlands they love
these water holding containers in our
backyards
and as we do a more a better job of
creating these opportunities like
rainwater tanks in our backyards maybe
we're creating that creating an
opportunity for these mosquitoes to move
in
the yellow fever mosquito the ed's
aegypti was actually once common in
sydney but during the 50s it disappeared
one of the reasons for its disappearance
could well have been the fact that we
moved away from rainwater tanks
and now rainwater tanks are coming back
they're going to become more common and
could that see the return of these
mosquitoes
i certainly don't i certainly hope not
so what can our authorities do about
reducing the mosquitoes associated with
these these greening cities that we're
dealing with
there's a role for our local authorities
to consider mosquitoes when they're
building wetlands creating wastewater
recycling schemes
regulating the installation of rainwater
tanks
because these are dynamic systems
it's not just about how you design them
and build them but it's how you maintain
them
you can't just build them and walk away
because as these as we've learned
with these habitats degrade they become
more suitable for mosquitoes
these types of structures these wetlands
in our cities are great they help reduce
pollution they help store water but we
don't want them to be become an
opportunity for mosquitoes
but what about us there's a role for
local government for our local
authorities but how can we help protect
our families and our friends from the
impact of mosquitoes associated with a
greening city
i'm going to leave you with three tips
that can help you stop the bite of
mosquitoes and the buzz of mosquitoes
this summer
first of all
don't create opportunities for
mosquitoes in your backyard
anything that traps water after rainfall
will be a source of mosquito so tip out
cover up or remove these water holding
containers in your backyards
screen your rainwater tanks
clean your gutters and your drains
reduce that standing water that
mosquitoes love so much around our homes
secondly
insect repellents are a safe and
effective way to avoid mosquito bites
when you're choosing a formulation from
the local pharmacy or the supermarket
make sure you apply it as a nice even
coat over all exposed areas of skin
don't put it on like perfume a dab here
or there is not going to provide
protection unless you've got complete
cover those mosquitoes will find a way
to find that gap in your repellent and
bite
lastly a way that you might be able to
stop the buzz of mosquitoes
why not just switching on a fan
we know that operating a fan in our
bedroom can help reduce those mosquitoes
that come in and buzz around our ears at
night it disperses the smells and the
temperatures around our body that
attracts them
it might even make them it might make it
a bit harder for that mozzie to fly
around and find us as well
so finally i want to leave you with
thought
we may hate mosquitoes
and i understand i don't want to convert
you into loving these bloodsuckers but
we need to understand them
because if we can't understand the
diversity of mosquitoes and their
relationships with the environments
we're creating in our greening cities
it's going to become a much greater
struggle to kind of reduce the burden of
disease that might come with them and
unfortunately mosquitoes are going to be
yet another challenge we face as we move
forward into our future cities under the
impact of a changing climate